From playing ping pong with water droplets,
to lighting things on fire in microgravity
to growing space salad… astronauts on the
International Space Station get to experiment
in one of the most unique laboratories known
to man.
Hovering 240 miles about us, the ISS hosts
scientific investigations that not only benefit
us here on Earth, but will hopefully bust
us out of orbit one day.
But how do these experiments get designed
and prepped for microgravity?
We’re here at the Kennedy Space Center to
find out.
CRS-15 is a joint SpaceX, NASA, and CASIS
cargo resupply mission, carrying over 5,900
pounds of gear and scientific research to
the ISS.Aboard this SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket
will be 20 moustramauts, an artificial intelligence
assist named CIMON, and over 20 scientific
payloads.
At the Space Life Sciences Lab, researchers
are busy prepping an experiment on space algae,
a potential food source for deep space missions.
“Algae is really versatile.
They’re very rich in protein, and have a
bit of starch, and a fair amount of oil in
them.
It’s very photosynthetically efficient,
so you don’t need a lot of light.
You need much, much less light than you would
need for growing say lettuce.
The way that people are producing algae for
say biofuels… they grow them in liquid because
you can get much higher yield, much faster
growth.
That was the goal… to figure out how can
we grow algae in liquid, in a microgravity
environment.
We’re using those gas permeable bags to
then be able to grow liquid cultures.
Then we put a large amount of those cells
into a starter culture.
That culture sits in the dark for about a
week before it then gets installed into the
veggie unit for light.”
Scientists like Dr. Settles work closely with
CASIS payload analysts to make sure their
experiments are ready for launch.
“Part of my job as a payload developer is
to try and take the experiment that the researcher
wants to do and make it as simple as possible
for the crew.
When the crew is up there working, after a
long day, you don’t want very complicated
procedures.
You don’t want complicated hardware.
You want to make it clean and simple.
We load that up and get it ready for flight.
We package it in a flight approved foam container
and then we’ll take that over to the Kennedy
Space Center to hand it over to the NASA group.”
NASA’s Space Station Processing Facility
is a three story, 457,000 square foot building
where ISS modules and flight hardware are
manufactured.
It’s also the next checkpoint for science
experiments en route to the ISS.
The space algae payload, which looks a bit
like a pizza delivery, is handed off and vetted
by NASA employees before being loaded onto
the spacecraft, ready for lift-off the next
morning.
At about nine minutes and thirty seconds after
liftoff, the SpaceX Dragon spacecraft separated
from the Falcon 9 rocket, heading towards
the ISS.
Three days later, the ISS’s Canad-arm2 played
a careful game of robotic catch with the Dragon.
“Capture complete… looking forward to
really exciting weeks ahead and getting started
on some great experiments.”
“Our payload is scheduled to be installed
in the hardware on space station within 24
hours of docking on ISS.
So the samples that we’re working with are
live organisms, so they can’t stay in stowage
for too long.
Once our hardware is installed in veggie,
our experiment will run for one month.”
The hope with this investigation is to see
how microgravity stimulates changes in different
algae strains.
By identifying genes associated with faster
growth, Settles and his team can hopefully
better engineer algae for space food and fuel.
“The nice thing about algae is that it grows
relatively fast.
In three, six days you’re already producing
something as opposed to waiting three months
if you’re growing a large terrestrial plant…
it would help capture the carbon that the
astronauts are breathing out and then turn
it back into biomass.”
Technologies used for this space algae experiments
are already being used to help us grow crops
more efficiently, like the LED lights, watering
system, and the small compartments.
And with its high protein count, we could
be seeing algae-based snacks and meals in
our diet one day.
That’s all thanks in part to experiments
like this one, which are just one of over
250 active scientific investigations happening
aboard that can benefit us here on Earth.
Want more science documentaries?
Check out this one right here, don't forget
to subscribe and keep coming back to Seeker
for more videos.